I just ran in the Assassin's Creed
obstacle course that's SDCC and it was a
minute 40 seconds Victoria can you play
evie frye voice mocap I challenge you
can you beat me I'm gonna take on this
challenge and I really hope I can
otherwise it's gonna be quite
embarrassing participant for an assassin
to lose so yeah here we go let's see
what I can do
1:07 yes it was 107 Alexa you you smoked
me and we shook on it you will be on my
comm so now you did that in you did that
in sneakers but you actually mocap the
game in heels I did I was gonna do the
course in heels but I you know I I need
to get around comic-con so but yeah I
did the whole motion capture in heels
EB wears Hills so I wanted to wear heels
and it's really yeah it's important for
the movement and the walk of the
character so I have to ask how does it
feel to be the first playable female
assassin in a mainline Assassin's Creed
game it feels pretty damn good
yeah it's great it's um it's so cool for
the female gamers as well to have a
playable female character for this
franchise and it's such a great period
of time the Victorian era we meet some
amazing characters I can't say too much
but it is a is gonna be a great game
awesome well you guys saw it here first
Victoria Atkin voice and mocap err of
evie frye smoked me in the Assassin's
Creed obstacle course thank you for
tuning in see gamespot.com for all the
rest of your San Diego comic-con news
keep watching and thank you thank you